[müzik]
Evet. Şimdi ne kaldı? İlk çağdaki
Anadolu uygarlıkları kaldı. Mezopotamya.
Canım benim.
Anadolu
doğudan geldi. Molguşu
aklıma nereden geldiyse şimdi soru. Soru
Mısır'da niye sadece Mısır var da
Anadolu'da Lidya'sı, Hidi, Urartusu,
İyonu, Guyonu bitmiyor. Niye? Tek bir
sebep var, tek bir cevap var. O da şu.
Kızları güzel değil. Değil abiciğim.
İklimi güzel. O da değil abiciğim. Ne?
Asıl cevap şu. Tamam. Bunların hepsi tam
ortada. kabakin ortasında falan. Ama
asıl sebep şu su. Su bir yerde bir
uygarlık kurabilmen için ne lazım? Su
lazım. Anadolu'nun elinde de su var mı?
Hamd olsun var. Anlaştık. O yüzden bu
kadar çoktur. Şimdi Anadolu'da beş
uygarlık var. Bunlardan ilki Hititler.
Tamam. Hititler. Bak tek tek anlatılarak
gelelim. Hititler nerede? Başkent
Hatluşa Çorum civarında. Tamam mı?
Ohat'ta kuruldular. Kızırmak yayının bu
tarafına doğru gelir. Başkent Hatşa'ta
bunlar Anadolu'da. Zomzomlasana Erdem
Şokamara. Tam denk geldik. Bak al.
Anadolu'da bunlar nerede? İşte Çorum,
Çorum, o Alacöy o civarlardalar değil
mi? Anadolu'da siyasi birliği ilk
sağlayan bunlardı. Bunlar önce feodal
beyliklerdi. Sonra krallık, sonra
imparatorluk. Yürüdüler gittiler. Tamam
mı? Ya yaprak testlerde gelirse
Anadolu'da siyasi birlik sağlayan kim
derlerse Hititler, Etiler falan
diyebilirsiniz. Bir de haddiler maddeler
var. Ayrıntısında bu olmanın anlamı yok.
Tamam. Bunların kral tabarna denilen
kralları var. Bir de kral içe tabananna,
havanna denilen milli yenge var. Hoppa!
Bir şeyi ilk kez görüyoruz. Kralın
yanında yengeyi de gördük. E demek ki
kadın da yönetimde söz sahibi mi? Evet
ya kelime olarak sorarlar. Hatta
bunların bir de neyi var? Pankuş
meclisi. Oha! Hem kral, başra, başargıç,
başkomutan, başzıkkım, baş her bir halt
değil mi? Yenge var. Bir de üstüne ne
var? Kralın yanında pankuş meclisi
denilen bir şey var. Bak ilkel cinsten
meclisin varlığı ilkel demokrasi vardır
diyebilir miyim? Bunu ben ders
anlatırken çocuğun biri soruyordu. İlkel
demokrasiden nasıl oluyor diye. Senin
ağzını burnunu dedim susmu yusmu. Vurdun
mu burnun kulağına varır. Ondan sonra
beni şikayet edebiliyorsan bak ilk
demokrasi vardır. La kurban olduğum işte
demokrasinin az gelişmişi. Halkın
seçimle yönetime katılımı gibi günümüz
gibi nisbi temsil böyle bir şey yok. Ama
kralın yanında kralın yanında onun
egemenliğini kısıtlayan bir meclis var.
Yani meşruti yönetim vari bir şey var
mı? Var. Böyle diyeceğiz. Anlaştık. Ve
bu Hititlerden bileceğiniz bunlar
doğrucu Davutlar abim. Tamam mı? Bunlar
öldüklerinde kralları tanrılarına hesap
verecek diye kralın her yaptığı işi
yazmışlar. İyi yaptığıyla, doğru
yaptığıyla, yanlış yaptığı, eksik
yaptığını da yanlışma yazmışlar. Kralın
yanına koymuşlar. E Tanrına yalan
söyleyebilir mi? E söyleyemem. Ee fark
etmeden o belgelerle işte anal denilen
yıllıklar yazdılar ama fark etmeden bir
şeyi başlattılar. Neyi? Objektif tarih
yazıcılığını başlattılar. Ulan her şeyi
yazarsan doğruyu da yanlışı da her şeyi
de değil mi? Normalde tarihçiler ne
yapar? Hala bizim Osmanlı tarihçileri
yemin ediyorum var ya bak bizim Osmanlı
tarihçilerinden ben de Osmanlı
tarihçisiyim hani Moğaç meydan
muharebesi 2,5 saat sürmüş. Tamam. Adam
10 cilt kitap yazmış. 2 saatlik savaşa
lan ne yazdın o kadar kurban olduğum ya.
Hadi 3 cilt savaşa katılanların sonla
beraber atları. Lan ne yazdın o kadar?
Ne nasıl ballandırdın değil mi? Ama
Karlovça anlaşmasıyla Balkan
topraklarının üçte kaybettik bir cümle.
Hep biz yendik canım. Bir de onlar yeni
versin demiş. Geçmiş bak objektifliği
anla şimdi anla. Bu adamlar fark etmeden
objektif tarih yazıcılığını başlattılar.
Neyle? Anal denilen yıllıklarla.
Tanrılar işte hesap vereceğiz. moduyla
her şeyi doğru Davut gibi yazmışlar. Bak
soru olarak gelse bu gelir. Pankuş
meclisindeki o meşruti monarşi muhabbet
halkın kısmen yönetime katılması, kralın
yetkilerinin kısıtlanması, yengenin
olması bunlar soru olarak gelir. Yoksa
sana kaldırıp da ilk tavan anına kimdir?
Ne bilen kimdir? Yani hani bu
beraberinde bin tanrı ili denilir. Abo
bunlar bulduğu tuttuğu tanrıya
inanmışlar. Bunların meşhur bir Hitit
Güneş kursu vardır bilir misiniz? Etiank
günümüzde de var mesela bu Ankara
kızlarda da var mesela 3 2 k bunlardan
kalma işte anlaştık bilin tanrı il bu
kadar çok dine inanmaları toplumun
kapalı olmadığını gösterir açıklar. Ne
gelirsen gel buyur gel modundalar değil
mi? Kadeş anlaşması mısırlılarla
yaptılardı Suriye toprakları için.
Hatırladın mı? Tartilen ilk anlaşmaydı.
Medeni kanun vari bir şey de yapmışlar.
Lan zaten kadın yönetimde söz sahibi.
Kadının söz hakkı var.
Medeni kanunu da ilk medeni kanunu da
böyle kısmen bunların yaptığı
söylenilir. Bir de Telepun'in veraset
yasası var. Veraset ne? Ülke anadanın
ortak malı. Ben öldükten sonra şu geçsin
başa falan diye böyle bir bunu soruların
içinde verirler, anlatırlar size. Tamam
mı? Ülke anadanının ortak malı anlayışı
vardır gibi gelir. Ama ben burada şundan
bahsedeceğim. Bunların Hititlerin acayip
bir kral isimleri var. Telepuniş
hattuili şippu liliuma
üli üçlü üşl oğlum hatta gittik biz
akerle beraber Çoruma falan ol yürü
dedim hadi kokoreç yelim dedin tamam mı
şip luma kokareç hattuşeli ne bile
beyran la oğlum bu ne la abi ne
dedim oğlum dedim kralları anladın al
aklınızda bulunsun değişik isimlerde
olduklarını bilin ve şu an Konya Reyli
civarında mesela ne var yazılıkaya İbris
kabartmaları var Bu onlardan kalma.
Kayalığı oraya oyup oyup oyup ne
yapmışlar? Gidin güzel yerdir. Su
kabardı. Su gözünden su çıkıyor falan
derler. Güzel. Hititler böyle bitti.
Anlaştık. Sonra ne tarafa doğru gelelim?
Bu tarafa doğru gidelim. En sonunda bunu
halledelim. Değil mi? Gel orta kameraya.
Gel orta kameraya. Frikler nerede?
Ankara Polatlı civarındalar. Ankara
Polatlı başkent Gordon. Tamam. Ankara
Polatlı'ya yakın. Tamam. Bilin. Bunlar
süper tarım yapıyor o coğrafyada. Abo
hatta toru, tarımı koruyan kanunlar
yaptılar. Dediler ki öküz kesene, saban
kırana ölüm cezası ver dediler. Peki
ödüllü soru. Bunların öküz kesene, saban
kırana ölüm cezası vermesi hayvanları
kutsal saydıklarını gösterir mi?
gösterir
seni şuradan vallaha bak bir tane ya
kurban olduğum kızdığı zaman Celar Hoca
kızdı diyorsunuz ondan sonra Instagram'a
oraya buraya bu adam bizi izliyor mu
kızıyor kızıyor deyip şey atıyorsunuz
resel shorts bilmem ne editleyip
atıyorsunuz kurban olduğum bunlar öküze
tapmıyor öküz o dönem öküz değil öküz o
dönem ne traktör la traktör traktör yan
öküzü kesersen tarlayı kim sürecek
sabanı saban ne lan ze kuş Çağı sabah ne
hani böyle üçlü pulluk gibi oluyor da
öküzün arkasına takıyorsun da tarlayı
sürüp gidiyorsun ya. A onun adı pulluk
işte saban işte. Anladın bunlar tarım
aleti. Adamlar ne yapmışlar? Tarımı
koruyan kanunlar yapmışlar. Yani
ekonomik uğraşıları hukuklarını
şekillendirmiş mi? Şekillendirmiş. Bak
böyle yorumlarla gelir. Tamam.
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi Anadolu
uygarlıklarında ekonomik uğraşıların
hukuku şekillendirdiğine kanıt olarak
gösterilebilir? Friklerde öküz kesene,
saban kırana ölüm cezası verilmesi.
Anladın? Adam tarımla uğraşıyor. Tarımı
koruyan kanun yapmış. Yoksa öküz kutsal
falan değil. Öküze tapmıyor. Allahu
ekber. Öküze tapım yok. Anladın mı?
Öküze tapmıyor. O hintliler ineğe
tapıyor onlar. Tamam. Bin bu ayrı bir
mesele. Öküz kutsal değildir. Yaprak
testlerde gelecek karşına. Ben biliyorum
gittim koyunu. Beraberinde bereket
tanrıları bile kibele. Kibele bereket
tanrısı. Bunun iki figürü vardır. Bir
böyle şişman bir kadındır.
Doğulurganlığı, bereketi şeyi yapar
diye. Bir tane de şöyle bir şey var.
Tamam mı? Neyse anladın sen. Bereketle
alakalı. O bak bu bile aynı. Ya bunların
ekonomik uğraşıları, tarımla uğraşıları
dini inanışlarını da şekillendirmiş mi?
Niye savaş tanrısı değil? Niye bilgelik
tanrısı değil? Niye ne bileyim tanrı şey
değil de tarih tanrısı değil de niye
bereket tanrısı? E işte tarımla
uğraştıklarından dolayı. Ve beraberinde
Ankara civarında ne uğraştılar?
Küçükbaş. hayvancılıkla uğraştılar.
Bizim Ankara'nın yok mu la kılkeçisi,
tipik keçisi. Ee e bundan küçüpş
hayvancılıklar bak mesela Osmanlı'da
Ankara aldığı zaman o sof kumaş vardır.
Hala Ankara'da kalede devam eder o
işler. Bilin küçükbaş hayvancılık bir
yerde coğrafya bilgisi. Küçükbaş
hayvancılık varsa orada otomatikman şu
da vardır. Ne vardır? Dokuma tekstil
dediğiniz işte vardır. O küçükbaş
hayvanın kılı yünü, tüğünü eğirip ip
yaparsın dokursun. Değil mi? Al.
Bunların tapates denilen halıları var.
Dünyaca ünlü tapates denilen halıları
var. Yaprak testlerde falan gelir
karşınıza. Tamam. Bilin. Beraberinde
fibula denilen neyi bulmuşlar? Çengelli
iğneyi bulmuşlar. Abem 2000
7'de miydi? 2008 mi? Fibula kemik gibi
işte böyle çengel iğne gibi
kullanıyorlarmış. Tamam mı? 2007 miydi?
2008 miydi? Bu 8. sınıf sınavı o zaman
için. Şimdi TEOK şeyde o zaman LGS'de o
zaman için TEOK muydu, OKS miydi, SBS
miydi ne sürekli 3 adında. Tamam mı? O
zaman sadece sekizler değil, yediler,
sekizler üç defa diliyordunuz sınava. 6.
sınıf ünitesidir. Altılara sorduları.
Tapates, Fibula, Fable, işte Kibele
kimden bahsediyordur diye cevabı Frikya
verdilerdi. Anladın? Aha genel kültür
olsun. Fibula çengelliğini yemiş. Fable
türünün görcüleri. Hani hayvanlar
konuşturuluyor ya. edebiyatta onun
öncedir. Bir de kralları var. Eşek
kulaklı Midas
bildin. Bizim o dinar su çıkan
taraflarında mesela mağarası vardır.
Bunun kulakları eşek gibi. Berbere tıraş
oluyor. Kurban oldum. Berber şimdi
berber abi önüne oturan herkesten
muhabbet ediyor. Ondan duydun ona. Ondan
duydun ona. Vallaha diyor bak benim
diyor bırak kulaklarına bak senin diyor
beynini patlatırım diyor. Berber bir
söylemek istiyorum canatlı üç söylemi
yok. Gidiyor abim o dinar suçkanın o
taraflarda kayalıklara. Tamam mı?
Kayalıklara bağırıyor. [çığlık]
Bizim kral var ya. E eşek kulaklı Midas,
koca kulaklı Midas, eşek kulaklı. Orası
dünyanın doğal amfiblikatörü diye
geçiyor. Yani şey hoparlör gibi. Lan
oradan bağırdığı bütün Ankara oralarda
duyuluyor. Berberin bekesini kesmiş
bizim kral. Bilin yani hani hatta gaval
maval oralardan çıkıyor. Bilin. Tamam
mı? Gene kütür olsun. Sonra doğusunda ne
var? Lidyalılar var. Lidyalıları
sorarlar. Lidyalılar bu başkent Sart
işte bu Manisa civarına denk geliyor.
Gediz ve Menderes ırmaklarının suladığı
verimli topraklarda kuruldular. Gediz
Menderes arası. Tamam. Bunların başkent
Sart başkent Gordon başkent Hatluşaş
başkent Van Tuşpa. Anladın? Otorite var.
Merkez otorite var. Siyasi birlik var.
Böyle bileceğiz. Tarımla uğraştılar.
Süper tarım yaptılar. Süper tarımdan da
süper ticaret yaptılar. İşte ihtiyaç
fazlası. Üretim tarımdan sonra neyi
getirdi? Ticareti getirdi. Değil mi?
Bunlar abim müthiş bir ticaretle
uğraşıyorlar. Hatta başkentleri SAR'tan
başlayıp te
gel öbür kameraya t aşağılara işte
MEB'in eski kitabı eee bu şey Asurların
abilerin Ninova'ya kadar diyordu. Yeni
kitap Pers topraklarına kadar diyor.
Yani Anadolu'nun bir ucundan gel büyük
kameraya tamam. Orta kameraya gel tamam.
Anadolu'nun bir ucundan t İran'a, Irak'a
orara kadar gidiyor. Tamam. Böylece doğu
batı alışverişi arttı mı? Kral yolu
kimden kalma? Lidyalılardan kalma. İşte
bu kral yolundaki canlı ticaret hacmi
onlara bir şeyi buldurdu. Neyi? Parayı
buldurdu. Parayı. Parayı. Elektron
dedikleri parayı buldular. Hah. Hayırlı
uğurlu olsun. Bir neyimiz eksikti? Para.
Önceden neydi? Takas usulüydü. Tamam mı?
Ne yapıyordun? İki tavuk veriyordun. Bir
horoz alıyordun. Bir bu işte buğday
veriyordun. arpa alıyordun. E şimdi para
çıktı. Hadi hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Hatta
bankacılık sistemi falan oluşturdu
bunlar. E para var, şey var, canlılık
var ama işte Allah çok verip azdırmasın,
az verip bezdirmesin. Abi bunlar parayı
çok bulunca paralı asker bulundurdular.
Paralı asker bulunduran devletlerin sonu
hep aynıdır. Kibrit çakmışsın gibi
birden
olur. Sonra birden biter gider. Niye?
Düşünsene ikimiz Lidyalılarda paralı
askeriz. Aylık 20.000 dolar maaşla
çalışıyoruz. 20.000 elektrona
çalışıyoruz. Abi 2 yıl çalıştık. Parayı
biriktirdik mi? Biriktirdik. Milyon
dolar para var mı? Var. Artık ben
yemişim Lidya kralını. O dangalak için
ben ölür müyüm ben? Ne yapalım? Miamiye
tatile gidelim dik değil mi? Ordu
bunları bıraktı gitti. Bunlar da sap
gibi orta yerde kaldı. Milli ordun
olmazsa seni götürüverirler. Paralı
asker seni bir yere kadar idare eder. Do
you under stand?
He mi? He. Tamam. Bak böyle bilin
burayı. Lidye meselesi de bu. Parayı
bilin. Kral yolunu bilin. Bitti. Bitti.
Bu kadar. Anlaştık. Mesela burayla
alakalı tartışmalar vardı. Kral yolu
nerede başlıyor, nerede bitiyor diye.
Başladığı yer sıkıntı yok. Başkent sart.
Tamam. Buralardan başlıyor. Bittiği yer
sıkıntıydı. Tamam mı? İşte Aur başkenti
Ninova'da mı? Bin Perskenti şeyde mi?
Persapolis'te mi? Ne bilen ne bilen
nerede mi diye. Tamam mı? ÖSYM sorduğu
zaman 34 tane bilgiyle geliyor. Kral
yolunu yapan ulustur. Parayı bulan
ulustur. Başkentleri sarttır. Kim? E
kim? Lidyalılar. Bitti işte bu kadar.
Öküz altında buzağı aramanın anlamı yok
yananı. Çok bilen çok yanılıyor. Bilin.
Beraberinde gel şu Zomz kamerasına. Batı
Anadolu sahilinde de birileri var. Kim
onlar? İyonya dediğiniz işte bu Yunan'ın
ataları. Bunlar Yunan'nın devamı gibi,
beraber gibi. Onlarla düşünün. Tamam mı?
Bunlar da abeciğim Batı Anadolu
sahillerine sıkışmış durumdalar. Neden?
Neden? Çünkü doğularında güçlü bir Lidya
var. Lidya bu İyalıları içeriye sokar
mı? Sokmaz. Neden? E kral yolu buradan
buraya gayirse para bunlara gider.
Anladın? O yüzden İyonyalılar Batı
Anadolu sahiline sıkıştılar. Tamam.
Doğuya doğru gide güçlü bir Lidya var.
Bunlar polis denilen şehir devletleriyle
yönetildiler. Ne işte onlar? Efes polis,
Fochopolis, Metropolis, Indiana polis,
hadi ne bilen ne polis, yetiş 112 polis.
Bu şehir deretleri hep aynıydı. Merkezi
otorite yok, siyasi birlik yok. Başta
despot zalim bir adam yoksa özgür
düşünce bilim var diyorduk değil mi? Al.
Bunlar kolonicilikle uğraştılar. Niye? E
Batı Anadolu sahil. O dönem turizm,
otelcilik mi var? Yok ki. Zayıf değil
mi? Kolonicilikle uğraştılar. Müthiş bir
kültür etkileşimi var. Özgür düşünce
ortamı olunca bilim adamları da
buralardan çıktı. İşte o başınızın
belası adamlar işte Hellen, Doğu, batı
sentezi işte bunlar işte bu beraberler
bunlar. Basınızın belası, Aristotales,
Pisagodo, Pisagor, Tukudides, Pilates,
Pilates yokla anladın mı? Hippokrat
falan hep buralardan çıkmalar. Anlaştık
yattı mı aklınıza? He mi İyonya bu
kadar. İyonya, Lidya, Frikya, Hitit.
Tamam. En sonuncu kaldı. Gel orta
kameraya. En sonuncu hangisi?
Urartular. Gel zom kamerasına gel.
Tamam. Kameramız çok. Gösterelim. Kurban
oldum. Var var ki gösteriyoruz deriz. Al
bir Urartular. Bunlar da başkent Van
Tuşba civarındalar ama bunlar bir
konfederasyon şeklinde. O ne lan?
Konfederasyon. Burası abiciğim göç
yollarının üzerinde. Nasıl oluyor bu
olay? Bir ekip buradan buraya doğru göç
ederkene 3 be kişi buralarda kalmış. Bir
ekip buradan yukarıya doğru göç ederkene
3 be kişi buralarda kalmış. Bir ekip
buradan bu yanına doğru göç ederken üçü
beşi burada kalmış. Biri buradan bu
yanına giderken üçü beşi burada kalmış.
Bunlar böyle öbek öbekler farklı farklı
millettenler. Ama şuradan ortak bir
düşman geldiğinde bunların hepsi
birleşiverdiler. Konfederasyondan kastın
ne olduğunu anladın mı? Bunlar hah
bilin. Bunlar müthiş maden ustaları.
Madencilikte çok ileri gitmişler. A
bilin beraberinde tarım için sulama
kanalları yapmışlar. Ulan Van
civarındasın. Su şimdi aşağıda. Tarlalar
nerede? Yukarıda. Sulama kanalları
yapmışlar ve o suyu yukarıya basmışlar.
Be adam nasıl ettiniz? Hidrolik ulus
deniliyor bunlara. Ulan hidrolik yok,
hidrofor yok. Ulan basınç yapacak suyu
basacak şey yok. Bunlar nasıl ettiler
bilemedik. Kafa çalışıyor mu? Çalışıyor.
Zehir mi? Zemzehir bilin beraberinde
mezar mimarisi. Mezarlarını oda şeklinde
yapmışlar. Eğer bir yerde mezar mimarisi
varsa tamam orada ahiret inancı yani
ölümden sonraki yaşamın varlığına olan
inanç da vardır diyebiliriz. Anlaştık.
Bilin. Beraberinde halde denilen
tanrıları varmış. Şimdi Anadolu bu. Gel
gel. Anadolu'daki ab uygarlığı
biliyorsun. Hitit, frik, Lidya, İyon,
Urartu. Mezopotamya'daki beş uygarlığı
biliyorsun. Sümer, Asur, Babil, Akat,
Elam. Karşılaştırmalı sorular. Şimdi
sana soruyorum. Hangisi daha ileri?
Anadolu mu, Mezopotamya mı? Mezopotamya
daha ileri bir uygarlık. Bak,
paragraflar verirler,
karşılaştırtırırlar. Sana kazanım bu.
Niye? Önce Sümerler buldu yazıya. Onlar
Sümerler yazıyı bulup da ilk çağ
geçtiğinde biz halen daha Yontuk Taş,
Nebilen Calıtaş. Anadolu eski yani
Anadolu'daki çok yer öyle işte Çorum
Alacı Hükte Hatşa ne bileyim işte şey e
Alişar'dır. E işte şey Çatalöyük Öyük
Konya Diyarbakır Çayönlü bunlar hep bir
işte şeyde aman lan beyin istiyor değil
yetişemiyor. Anadolu'daki ilk üretim
merkezi, ilk yerleşim merkezleri gibi
geçer. Çok su olduğu için çok da devlet
kurulmuştur. Ama ama abeyciğim burada
bileceğiniz bir önemli olay var. Şu
Urfa'daki
Göbeklitepe kazısı buraları komplecene
değiştirdi
bu Göbeklitepe. Tamam. Yani kuvvetli
ihtimalle burası da Türkler, Türk
motifleri falan çıkınca zaten şeyi
bıraktılar. Gazıyı araştırmacı
bıraktılar. Niye derler mi la? Türkler
dünyanın en eski uygarlığıdır. Türk
izleri vardır, bilmem ne vardır derler
mi? Biz Anadolu'ya 1071'de geldik
sanıyoruz meğer daha öncesinde var
mıymışız? E varmışız. Anlaştık. Aha
Anadolu uygarlıkları meselesi de budur.
Buraya da bir ödev verdim. Tamam mı?
Anadolu'daki ilk üretim merkezi ile ilk
yerleşim merkezi bir yazın bakalım. Bir
Konya Çatalı Çatalıykle Diyarbakır
Çayönü. Hangisi hangisiymiş? Altına yazı
verin. Böylece Anadolu uygarlıklarını da
hallettik. İlk çağ uygarlıkları
meselesi, eski çağ medeniyetleri bitti.
Üniteyi bitirdik. A 34 videoda bitti.
Şimdi abdest alın gelin. İslamiyeti
kabul edeceğiz. Sonraki ders görüşmek
üzere. Haydi bakalım.